Les mecs qui sont bilingues, ceux qui parlent bien anglais
En général, ils se la racontent pas trop...
FAUX
Ce qui est bien, c'est que c'est pas la peine de leur demander s'ils parlent bien l'anglais
Ces mecs là, ils aiment bien nous le rappeler tous les trente-cinq secondes...
Ouais, j'écoute exclusivement du jazz manouche et de la minimale, umm meaning that
je confond les deux langues
Excuse-moi, tu me prête ton portable quelques secondes?
Bien sûr ouais !
Heu mais c'est en anglais, c'est normal?
Ah oui, nan c'est en américain ouais !
J'en ai marre de rêver en anglais, ca me saoule
ça m'énerve !
Nan mais c'est vrai, moi avec mes origines je pourrais jamais me la péter comme ça, euh...
Ca sera toujours nul
J'en ai marre de rêver en ch'ti (vieux dialecte du Nord)
Oui nan bah parce que je suis bilingue je suis bilingue ch'ti (vieux dialecte du Nord)
Oui j'ai vécu dans le nord
Bon, on va pas épiloguer
On ne peut pas se la pêter quand on parle ch'ti
J'ai l'impression que les bilingues, ils ont une sorte de besoin de te foutre la honte
et heu ils aiment bien te mettre dans des situations de manière à te rappeler que tu es une merde à côté d'eux
Boil in water and let it cook for 2 or 3 minutes approximately yeah, you know
Non je parle pas l'anglais
Pardon?
Je suis désolé, j'ai pas compris, je parle pas bien l'anglais comme toi
Tu parle pas l'anglais? C'est génial! Tu parles quelle langue?
A tel point parfois, moi je fais semblant de comprendre juste pour leur faire plaisir quoi
Ouais j'suis en train de lire le texte d'un auteur américain complètement chéper, tu vas adorer, lis ça !
Ouais, ok vas-y, alors I have been... been c'est quoi been?
Haha c'est génial
Le pire, c'est pendant les concerts parce que tu as des milliers de bilingues qui se cachent dans l'obscurité
Tu les vois pas forcément mais tu sais qu'ils sont là
Alors quand un chanteur entre deux chansons fait une petite phrase pour le public,
Bah tu as la moitié de la salle qui est comme ca
Et puis t'as les bilingues...
Haha, énorme, génial c'qu'il vient de dire !!
Amazing!
I speak English !!
Yes I am bilingue !
Mais attention hein, le chanteur peut dire n'importe quoi
Tu as toujours un bilingue qui se marre pour montrer qu'il a compris
Haha, excellent, amazing!
Mais il a dit... Il a dit quoi là..?
Il a dit: one two, one two, this is a test
Moi tous ces gens qui se la pètent, euh...
M'ENERVE!
PD
Enfin bon moi je m'en fous, c'est pas grave, voilà j'ai un niveau anglais normal, moyen heu...
bon ok, j'ai un niveau sixième (6th grade)
Je m'en fous parce que le francais, c'est déjà une belle langue
Ca me suffit
J'aime bien en fait quand les gens parlent francais parce que je me sens baigné dans toute une histoire
Camus, Marguerite Duras, Victor Hugo,
Le francais, c'est une langue vivante qui évolue chaque jour, une langue magique, belle, pleine de fantaisies et de couleurs
Rien qu'à voir avec mon quartier, les mecs qui parlent
Donc un message pour tous les gens qui sont bilingues
C'est tout là
Arrêtez de faire les malins
Parce que c'est pas malin
C'est pas malin, de se foutre de la gueule des gens
Nous, on est nuls, on parle pas comme vous l'anglais
Et c'est pas grave
Putain!
sinon j'ai vu que vous étiez de plus en plus nombreux sur la page Facebook 'Norman fait des vidéos'
Et ça me fais un gros plaisir
Love